we met briefly at the up fronts which
are up front and I'm told that it was a
quick encounter there's a lot of people
at those upfronts this is when they they
have uh everyone from the network go to
New York and meet the advertisers and so
I was there just a couple of months ago
you were last month and um what happened
during our interaction not that I don't
remember it well but you walked in and
of course it's obvious to see you
because you're a mile above everyone
else yeah and I was away I'm like a big
bird at Sesame Street yeah totally and
um I was with one of our Network guys
like the guy that signs everyone's
checks Hi and then
um
I just see you and he's like you're
gonna meet him right now and I was like
I don't know that's how I started
sweating again I did all the Emojis
again and you're like he was like no
this is happening right now and so I was
like okay
okay so you walk up and I'm five one so
I'm the shortest person you're the
tallest person I literally just see you
I look up like this I crane my neck back
and like all I could think of to say was
you're so tall
and then and that's all anybody says to
me right I'm sure yeah when I go places
because not that I'm so crazy tall but
just that I'm different I'm more taller
than they think if they've grown up
watching me on TV TV makes you about
that big so I'm bigger than they think
and so that's why people don't pop to me
because everyone says you're so tall
you're so tall you're so tall and I'm
like okay that's all I hear so you said
that to me and what did I say and then
you shook my hand and all you said was
you looked down and you go your hands
are so cold
and then someone swooped you away and I
just see a floating redhead just walking
away into the ground and I was like
one minute with Conan we said eight
words to each other it was a caveman
conversation yeah you're so tall your
hands are so cold by the way
that is my go-to line when I'm with the
ladies
I'll put my hands in the freezer for a
bit yeah okay okay that shows you how
cool I am with the ladies should I just
say though that last shirt up front I
meant yes and we were at the king crab
station it was very
heavy and champagne and we had this like
existential like spiritual wonderful
conversation we spoke many words
together yes I do remember yeah I gave
me advice on the industry and working on
the show I bet he did yeah
come on
look Ali you're a beautiful woman but no
offense but we were in front of the crab
station yeah that's true my attention
that's Andy's Mo I got my ammo which is
your hands are cold in his I got some
crab for you up there
I have to call Andy out though because
at upfront you were eating in the hotel
lobby and I was very excited because our
conversation last year was so special
and I was like and did you
did you have this great conversation you
looked at me like oh yeah uh-huh so I
don't know if you did remember me I do
remember now I did okay no but there
just wasn't any shellfish this time
around well there's no shellfish there's
no magic right okay so if I've been like
this with the giant crab leg you would
have been like oh yeah
no but when you said oh yeah no but
there was no context when you reminded
me then yeah
you're right there you go these men they
just Allie you've spent most of your
interview confirming that we know who
you are
hahaha
[Applause]